Some of the most important regions for turning on
coding genes the right time and the right place are
called promoters. A promoter is simply a region of
non-coding DNA that initiates transcription of a particular gene. Now
what's really important to realize if this is new
to you That this is not a start codon. This
is not the same thing as a start codon. Remember
that a start codon is important for translation of an
[UNKNOWN]
sequence into amino acids. The promoter is indicating
the initiation of transcription which is very different, right,
it's the first step in the central dogma.
Take a look here at this hypothetical gene sequence.
We have five axons in purple, and four
entrons in between these five axons. This arrow right
here indicates the initiating point for transcription. The
plus one says hey, this is the first nucleotide
that's transcribed here in this processing going from the gene
to the MRNA copy. And transcription is going to start here
at this plus one site and go all the way
to this line here, where it stops. The introns will be
spliced out, and we'll get an mRNA copy of just
the exons. What I want you to tell is, which region
you think is most likely to be the promoter region.
This region here in front of the gene before transcription begins?
This region here, in the middle of the gene, where we see it spans one exon, an
intron, and another exon? Or do you think
it's this region over here, after transcription's already terminated
for the gene? Go ahead and pick which
region you think is most likely the promoter. And
then I want you to tell me why by
writing a brief response in this text box here.